mic Montone of course of the New York
radio Montone family and handsome Rob
went over to comic-con but you guys
didn't go to the panel so you guys were
interviewing people at comic-con a
couple days ago we watched the first
clip you guys talking to spider-man yeah
a really organic and good homemade
spider-man cost
I couldn't tell it was even homemade no
I thought it was like he had
superimposed himself into the film yeah
I thought tom hollie fake ones like
before Tony Stark hooked him up with the
real suit I see yeah I see spittin facts
I don't understand the reference
Travis give me a favor nice like these
spittin facts thank you yeah as soon as
you heard it did you know it how exactly
yeah strange is pretty good isn't it
great that when they're when they're
just when it's just met with my utter
silence just stunned disbelief of those
with ears and don't even want to
acknowledge it you know I had the intro
from Monday's show but now I have
another one spittin facts that's right
alright so who do we want to start with
Mike if we go Travis would have put him
in the the order that that he liked best
I think he's right Thanos was was a you
guys had started Thanos oh good yeah
Thanos of course he wiped out the Marvel
x-men and now he's pretty good costume
it is a good costume he's a Comic Con
yeah he's got the cardboard that makes
his arms bigger he's got the big fake
jaw and everything yeah a lot of detail
in that costume a lot it was good let's
take a listen a moment for Sirius XM
wait the jar doesn't move no passports
that you're planning on engaging in mass
amounts of of genocide how do you
respond to that I wouldn't call it I
would say it was good for the universe
I'd say good for resources good for the
life forefront the prosper possible he
doesn't sound like Thanos no if a no
sounds very confident it's not a very
powerful voice say yeah I'd say it's uh
good for the universe that's uh very
good possible and says maybe she does
yeah I do like that mike is like really
like no you should you have to answer to
this he's like I'm just trying to get a
poster I'm trying to get an exclusive
poster at booth 894 like you know I I
don't need to deal with this right now
so you found dr. strange at comic-con as
well we did I had no idea who it was Rob
had to to fill me in on that one he was
one of the to me lesser-known guys I
pretty much know who Batman Superman and
spider-man I mean in the gym to be
watching superhero movies what are you
gonna you know trigger that muscle milk
exactly exactly I mean you could watch
Marvel movies and drink muscle milk but
not when you're lifting that's a lot to
do at once
yeah how was Doctor Strange he's an
interesting cat yeah we learned a little
bit about him that's when you know it's
too much with the Marvel movies when
Doctor Strange has his own multiple
movies that are just his I'm sure yes
I'm sure it's fantastic Troy you want to
go check out a Doctor Strange movie yeah
you don't want to see that oh no he's
got a rewatch bohemian right well you
see dr. strange no no he makes her miss
miss it out makes he makes what spirals
in the air and those are holes in time
oh yeah all right let's let's hear from
dr. strange there is he's doing the
doctor strange things he's making his
holes in time he's not going anywhere
can you do that you you kind of hold
your hand like this almost sort of kind
of like this
yeah so what would you what you say that
allegations that when you do that you're
signaling to white supremacists I would
say that it's a pretty it's a serious
allegation so he's doing the okay symbol
yeah the way that Doctor Strange makes
his holes he's doing that a okay thing
which I guess people think is a white
power so I'm guessing it's the KKK the
three fingers I think that it's like a
troll yeah oh this is arted and then
people started believing it and then at
some point
oh it's [ __ ] it just starts well I
think at some point it starts to melt
together where people who actually are
white supremacists are doing it because
people think it's the white supremacists
logo even though it's not but even
though they are so then it kind of is
well it started as used to just hold it
down and if someone looked you get to
hit him right yeah people started doing
it in pictures and then I guess like
left-leaning media caught on to it and
just launched it out there yeah it was a
white supremacist thing so the 4chan
guys were like well it is now right and
then yeah so you and you saw dr. strange
doing it and you are like you may be dog
whistling I love that these guys are
just dressing up and going to comic-con
and mike is comparing them to white
supremacists girl Mike isn't doing it
Mike is doing the reporter thing where
he is not doing it people are saying
he's mentioning allegation right this is
what reporters do they'll always go well
what how do you respond to the
allegations that what do you think about
the reports that respond to comments
yeah yeah I don't know no no no no I'm
just a messenger this guy has no idea
what to say do you think anybody was
sitting there watching this man dressed
up as dr. strange going like set the
white supremacist no one even considered
out no I love it
yes very serious a Penant supremacist
you're not social supreme I protect the
the whole earth basically I protect
Earth and the sanctum what's wrong if
you'd have no long if you met him before
he's currently back in the sanctum right
now eating a sandwich long your long yes
by my partner in crime is it appropriate
that sounds like an asian slur Wednesday
so he's okay with that he that's his
name every turn so I'm sitting there
watching and immediately I think why
would his name be a slur and it took
this poor guy like three excuses for her
son can just name his first response was
no he's okay we go back a little bit
he's currently back in the sanctum right
now eating a sandwich
long long yes my my partner in crime is
inappropriate that sounds like an Asian
slur I wouldn't say so he's okay with
that why wouldn't he just sit there and
look at you and go it's his name he's if
anybody makes fun of me he's just
digging himself deeper poor guy and I
love to that this whole thing started
with him saying he's eating a sandwich
thinking that was like a funny joke
imagine a superhero back at the lair
eating a sandwich and instead of like
giving him something on that and giving
him a chuckle like how long's eating a
sandwich you accused him of racism yeah
yeah racism is no laughing matter no
greater right like very very salient
point I'm glad that yeah I'm glad that
you went there absolutely well you know
I just protect the realm and that's got
it you know the sanctum you know as long
as they don't sit around anymore you
know there's a snaps fingers I'm cool
with that you know but again you're
you're signaling white supremacists with
your hand signal there you're calling a
guy a wonk an easily interpreted as an
Asian slur
how do you how do you answer that into
not 2019 it's y9c you know well you know
different different age different time
you know basically admit to you cos
you're why would you say that's not what
I'm doing
he say 2019 different time you know cuz
because in all of his times of comic-con
no [ __ ] has ever asked of these
questions before it's not prepared to be
accused of racism will like sounds
serious
and he's just portraying a character
accurately yeah Mike shame you know many
different dimensions and very different
like languages and slur so do you think
that's an acceptable answer though I
mean we could you could use that as an
excuse for anything
I mean think of all the the women who
were harassed in the 70s and people said
oh it was a different time back then
that doesn't make it wait wait wait wait
are you dragging dr. strange yeah me too
yeah you're calling this is a doctor
Matt Lauer you're dragging this
gentleman who's just dressed up as dr.
strange into like what you're doing is
you know your victim shaming media
people of this kind of bigotry who knows
what he does to women oh that's a fair
plan actually is a lot well for all
right I see once a so no no definitely
on the 70s no so you know if we're not
now you're either so minstrel shows back
in the old days you know you could look
back and say a different time but still
not right so is it okay to signal like
that and to call your friend walk it's a
power it's you know it's to move I used
to fight my enemies with you know again
signaling white supremacy I mean they're
going to be white supremacists out there
who see that and they say dr. Strange's
is down with he's down with the white
power
no I wouldn't say so I mean you might
not say so but I think a lot of people
would say that that's the message that's
being put out there I once I saw it is
great for that we disagree as Doctor
Strange you know you just allow any ties
to white supremacy yeah just about any
ties white supremacy yep pretty much
yeah well we're gonna hold you to that
and the press will be watching all right
what a funny thing Comicon - it says so
it's so you found the bat we did he was
very annoyed that we found him - he was
little he got old crank he seems a bit
curmudgeon yeah he already we're looking
at the first frame of this video and he
already is kind of like glaring it
what's the angle here what are you doing
really condescension his nose hangs out
underneath the bat nose that's not
supposed to happen no no no yeah it does
I he has a double dose here oh yeah yeah
yeah the bad nose is supposed to cover
it so then it's like that's his nose but
unfortunately it just looks like a
covering yeah yeah okay that's not the
angle you went though is it might know
an ill-fitting mask and you're the mask
doesn't fit just right and also you can
see the back of his neck yeah you can
definitely see the back of his neck you
can see a soul patch too can't you yeah
yeah Batman doesn't have a soul patch
does he know
also his Batman's turtleneck supposed to
go to his chin through his mane that's
an ill-fitting mask yeah it looks like
you spent like a good amount of time on
the costume and just skimped on the last
details the mass doesn't work doesn't he
has his badge Batman wouldn't wear a
badge all you mean is the eyes the
laminate I don't know wear a cape why
did you wear a cape it like to work you
know but we're like one of those old
rich guy capes yeah I'm gonna be cool
like a superhero cape like an Elvis cape
yeah yeah just like attached to his
hoodie runnin cape that's a good idea a
really good idea you spend a lot of your
time dealing with the penguin Joker
but they tend not to strike quite as
often as some of our lower-level
criminals that are really probably more
of a problem for Gotham residents we
have you know people masturbating and
defecating on the subway it's a plan to
handle that well all these other people
come into the city Huntress Catwoman
you know they I let them deal with those
things I mean you're sort of the prime
crime-fighting entity that the people of
Gotham have don't you think that there's
many responsibilities on on your part
and in Commissioner Gordon's part to
take care of this well yes and I also
think that people only want a report on
the the chokers and the Bane's of Gotham
no one wants to tell them that Batman
stopped the man masturbating on the
subway wait so he started by not taking
credit for it now he's decided oh I
found a new angle I'll pay so whole
schnozz is hanging out is there anything
more absurd looking than just the neck
of a turtleneck it's great it's like a
scarf or whatever to make it look like
the costume is connected underneath but
you could see the bottom of his neck
yeah and the top of it right so you can
see skin between his mask and his
turtleneck and you could see skin
between his shirt and his turtleneck
it's a stupid-looking yeah yeah quite
yeah it is a crime that goes on pretty I
mean multiple times a day you hop on the
the 7 train there's a get if you were to
ride that all day you'd probably see it
Oh a dozen [ __ ] and at least to
defecate errs
I do what I can I'm only one man Carol
this big place
you're a Batman though you kind of an
advantage you could you know swing from
subway car in a subway car and handle
this I'm assuming you know you got
something you could like shoot out wrap
up a master baiter you know prevent him
from getting that final ejaculatory
stroke in you know why not you know they
run 24/7 EMT so you won't give him that
no no shitty mustache you want to you
want to know why you won't stop people
from making the final I have a job to do
yeah hey guys
the subways are closed tonight which
they're not that's that sure he does he
does have a shitty dirt moustache
doesn't get rid of it they kind of shut
down from time to time but I mean
especially in the me to era do not feel
any kind of social responsibility oh did
you see that I a hundred percent saw it
so he goes up you can remind just a
little bit Troy because I don't want to
miss Mike's question but when Batman
goes up to rub his nose his mask falls
over his mask fold that can protect you
from anything got it to to take care of
subway [ __ ] when all these
innocent women are out there you know
being kissed on
I think I need to do a better job so in
this one way Mike he's so pissed yeah I
got me enough because now you're talking
about women actually getting attack
elated on your Batman comics and movies
is there a chance that we might see you
taking on you know perhaps the subway
stroker so I'm gonna say it's a safe
shot but no no I don't think people want
to see that every do you want to see
that you know so there's no sense of
social responsibility that says I have I
have these superpowers I should use them
to prevent women from being masturbated
on on the subway I should so so you know
I'll make sure that were in tune for all
of the
the subway strokers the subway stroker
that would be a be putting more focus
that would be a pretty terrifying
villain the subway stroker you know your
your ride and you don't leave lights go
out yeah what to do it the best is
watching these guys try to stay in
character yeah well you know Alfred
fastened to you and then thanks nothing
to you it's just Alfred Mike's like
subway stroker stop talking about
jerking off buing this constant verbal
diarrhea I just loved it like the
superhero is trying to wrap up the
interview and Mike just stays put and
just stays on the same line of
conversation well very good my job to
the bottom yeah good job Mike good job
Rob one more Jim and Sam catch up with
full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM f
[Music]